good morning everybody and welcome to
the 95th Academy Awards makeup and hair
styling Bake Off
[Music]
the first film we're going to look at is
All Quiet on the Western Front what's a
day in the life of All Quiet on the
Western Front you get there I figure
very very early in the morning and every
day was like I started in the night and
I finished in the night we had like 200
soldiers every day then getting the boys
ready everyone was like wigs of facial
hair dirt teeth because we didn't want
it to have the white cheese anymore then
getting into our ninja clothes and
marching to set basically to the
battlefield and what you have seen in
front of camera it looked the same
behind the camera
foreign
to do this movie you know what it is so
it's not I wasn't surprised yeah and I
have to say the crew starting from
director the camera costume design
production design they were amazing it
was such a collaboration of team I think
otherwise you can't do that kind of
movie
they can give us the power
to endure
and the strength to fight certainly one
of the standout makeups in the movie is
the Penguin it's not a makeup it's a
complete and utter transformation of
Colin Farrell can you tell me the
Genesis of how that character came about
I looked at it a different perspective
Matt Reeves had some ideas about what
the character was how he was a little
bit like Fredo John casale's character
from The Godfather I said how can I
incorporate a penguin in here so it's
the tone of the film was such a
realistic you couldn't go fantasy you
couldn't go Tim Burton you couldn't do
that
know my reputation so once you realize
that we had the freedom to kind of make
like the ultimate penguin that we were
really excited to do we then had to dial
in that realism so that it fit in the
movie because none of the other actors
in the movie are wearing Prosthetics I
felt like it was kind of a culmination
of all the makeups that Mike and I have
done together over the past 10 years and
really like using almost every trick in
the book that we could possibly think of
one of the main things that I think
about wakanda forever is that it's a
franchise that could have been over I
wouldn't have been here because we lost
our star what kind of movie gets a
chance to come back as a rebirth and we
got that opportunity and that's the most
beautiful thing
this movie was all about the women you
see this very few minutes actually the
main people are all about the women and
it's about their connection
and then we introduced a host of Marvel
characters that you get to see we were
really lucky that we had the opportunity
to resurrect an old civilization that
hasn't been seen on camera in a really
really long time and we got to create
that in the telekinil they are a Mayan
society and we had a professor of Mind
studies who really helped us identify
what the looks are and really
understanding the culture in itself
your future Mr Presley blazing before
you
reporting contracts television even
Hollywood what a great chance to create
these two iconic characters well one
iconic character and then the villain of
the piece and although Colonel Tom
Parker says in the film that he's not
the villain of the piece he definitely
is and then really the other bit was
Elvis's progression you know the more
Tom Parker got his claws into Elvis it
manifested in the way he looked right
through where he sings on chain Melody
several weeks before he passed away
still more
[Applause]
[Music]
a quick quote from director Darren
arafnoski when I decided to do this
movie one of my very first calls after
casting Brendan was to my makeup artist
Adrian Moreau I asked him can we do
something that's incredibly realistic
because if it's not gonna work or look
phony then we shouldn't do it
no pressure that's the first thing
and then the next thing he said is that
I I want to do this in five weeks and I
was like okay five weeks that's not a
whole lot of time because well by the
way we're gonna see him nude he's gonna
have short sleeves he's gonna have short
pants and then I implore them to give us
more time and rare things he actually
worked it out with production and we
ended up having 12 weeks to build the
makeup Sharon had asked if we could have
his hair very thin and every day it was
like I would look at it I'm like I think
I need to make it thinner and then also
trying to be able to make it a
progression to show his decline of
having heart failure